From the Dorothy Chandler Pavilion in Los Angeles, California,
it's the 51st Annual Academy Awards.
Welcome to the 67th Annual Academy Awards.
I'm very, very excited.
Welcome to the 74th Annual
Academy Awards.
This is my ninth time hosting the Oscars.
One of the nominees is Her.
And by her, I mean Meryl Streep.
Have you ever wondered what went on behind the cameras
after one of those unexpected moments at the Oscars?
Probably the only laugh that man will ever get in his life is by stripping off
and showing his shortcomings.
Why are are you laughing?
What? Is this this funny?
I don't really have a joke here...
The question, "what were they thinking?" ever occur to you during
an Oscar telecast?
Uma!
Oprah!
And welcome to the shoe.
Show.
I'm Elvis Mitchell, and this is your
official invitation behind the scenes at the Academy
Awards,
past and present.
Legendary host share moments, the glamour and glory of famous
moments in Oscars history.
I am not going to up what happened last year when you were, you know.
and reveal untold stories that will amaze and delight.
We'll also guide you into the future with inspiring interviews of the
brightest stars and their upcoming projects.
So Fa La La ya'll!
Take this ride with us to the 93rd
Oscars and celebrate everything you love about the people and films
that bring us so much joy
and that iconic award that turns them into legends.
And the Oscar goes to... Whoopi Goldberg!
We've got the jolts, the weird, the wild, the spontaneous, the raw
emotion that will take you right up to the big night.
You are the original superhero!
Thank you!
So I'm hyperventilating a little bit. If I fall over, pick me up because
I've got some things to say.
Remember to hit subscribe and download right now so you
don't miss this premier season of the Oscars podcast with Elvis Mitchell
That's a pretty hard, active act to follow.
You can also find more info about the podcast at Oscars.org or on social
@TheAcademy on Instagram, Twitter, and Facebook.